[موسيقى]
ماء الذهب الأزرق للشرق الأوسط
بينما النفط متوفر بكثرة في
الشرق الأوسط تقول اليونيسف إن المنطقة هي الأكثر
ندرة في المياه في العالم.
من بين 17
دولة تعاني من الإجهاد المائي في العالم 11
تقع في منطقة الشرق الأوسط وشمال إفريقيا بينما
تمثل الزراعة على مستوى العالم
سبعين بالمائة من استخدام المياه في منطقة الشرق الأوسط وشمال إفريقيا ،
فهي تمثل ثمانين بالمائة
أنا في الصحراء حوالي عشرين دقيقة
من  سحر
دبي الساحر وهذه الظروف الجافة القاسية هي التي
تحدد المنطقة والتي
تجعل ندرة المياه مشكلة كبيرة ، لكن بعض
الخبراء يقولون إن الأمر قد لا يتعلق فقط
بندرة المياه كما هو الحال مع إدارة المياه
في الواقع
لا يدرك معظم الناس هذا العالم
لا تعاني من أزمة مياه ليس فقط
الآن أو في المستقبل ،
ما تعانيه هو أزمة إدارة مياه ،
نحن لا ندير الأزمة بشكل صحيح
ما سيحدث  القلم هو
بسبب الإدارة السيئة
هناك ، ستواجه جميع البلدان بعض
الأزمات ، وستكون الأزمة في
المقام الأول ليس بسبب
ندرة المياه في معظم أنحاء العالم ولكن في
المقام الأول لتلوث المياه
فقط لإعطائك فكرة عن
استهلاك المياه  في المنطقة ، يوجد في الكويت
حوالي متر مكعب واحد من المياه العذبة
المتاحة للفرد سنويًا وهو ما
يكفي لملء ثلاثة أحواض استحمام قياسية
على النقيض من ذلك ، تمتلك إسرائيل حوالي
265 مترًا مكعبًا من المياه العذبة
المتاحة للفرد سنويًا ، وهذا
أقل بكثير من تعريف المياه
الفقر الذي يقل عن 1000
متر مكعب للفرد في السنة